howdy got lots of good stuff in stock
money can be hard to come by and final
fantasy 15
unlike other Final Fantasy games the
game prioritizes realism above all else
so veterans don't expect to get Gil from
a monster you slay in a dungeon you need
to be diligent about finding ways to
make ends meet
lest you catch yourself in the field
with weak weapons and zero healing items
to help you survive the journey to
reclaim your kingdom we've detailed some
of the best ways to make money in final
fantasy 15
hunting contracts are a great way to
earn Gil early on when you're traveling
stop by any local restaurant and chat
with the owner to check out the open
hunting contracts they have available
most contracts offer Gil for your
troubles
but others offer additional rewards such
as treasure healing items and
accessories however be wary of the
recommended level listed beside each
contract it's a waste of your time if
you take on a contract that you're in no
way prepared for so don't get cocky
hunting is one of the most consistent
ways of earning Gil so it's always in
your best interest to take on a contract
if you're free but keep in mind you can
only take one contract at a time so
choose your battles wisely let's go back
and play video games you wouldn't think
it but you can actually grow vegetables
in Final Fantasy 15 carrots to be exact
growing them can turn you a profit as
long as you have the patience to raise
them properly you acquire the ability to
grow carrots when you get to a cabin in
Cape time from there an npc gives you
carrot seeds that can be planted in the
worked soil up the hill near the cabin
after planting the carrot seeds rest
overnight and check on their progress if
a few begin to sprout you're free to
harvest them at any time however if you
wait longer you increase the chances of
more carrots sprouting once you're
satisfied
take your harvested carrots to the
restaurant owner standing beside the
tree and you'll offer to pay you 500 Gil
for each carrot you have the restaurant
owner also offers the trade you special
items for carrots you can get a random
weapon for four carrots random auto
parts for three carrots and whole lot
berries for two carrots unleash your
inner farmer after all that's the number
one skill you need to have as an heir to
the throne height
taking photos for the journalist named
VIN is an easy way to get rich quick so
if you're struggling for money seek out
his photography assignments when you
reach list aalam head down to the view
overlooking the cliff side you'll find
VIN there and he asks you if you can
take photographs of the world's
landmarks for his articles this time I
need a photo of the royal tomb that lies
in the fall grove this sidequest asks
you to go to a specific location take a
photo and return to VIN to complete it
you can go on a multitude of different
photography assignments so long as you
keep accepting his subsequent requests
and each time earns you hefty rewards
typically upwards of 12,000 Gil or more
however be mindful of the time of day
when you travel to the specified
destinations as you won't be able to
take the required shots at nighttime
time your journeys accordingly and seek
out overnight accommodations if it gets
too late
eventually this line of sidequest will
end after you've completed them all so
don't rely on this as your primary means
of earning Gil
[Music]
as you explore the world you'll gather a
multitude of treasures that can be sold
at shops for varying amounts of Gil
while you're encouraged to sell
treasures keep in mind they can also be
used towards the spell crafting process
if you're a heavy magic user double
check what effect the treasure you're
looking to sell has on your spell's
perhaps you might want to reconsider
selling that ancient dragon tooth so you
can use stop cast a spell that allows
you to halt enemies in their tracks
otherwise feel free to sell the treasure
you obtained you'll need all the Gil you
can get and that's for easy ways to make
Bank and Final Fantasy 15 for more
coverage on the game stay tuned to game
spot thanks come back soon
[Music]